Loki you're gonna start taking things seriously
clock's ticking clock's always ticking this has
any relevance or bearish this is the good part on
june 9. i am loki and i am burdened with glorious
purpose he's really arrogant the time for glory
is now come on what did you expect my new series
loki is coming soon to disney plus and to help
get you ready i'm going to catch you up in just
30 seconds my dad odin says my brother thor
could be king i'm jealous plus he's not my
real dad so i get my real dad to kill odin but
then i save him thor's mine anyway i'll be fine
cut to earth i steal the tesseract from shield
help with atari invade earth and the avengers stop
them and i go to jail until thor needs me to help
defeat the dark elves next thing you know i'm king
but everyone thinks i'm odin our sister heller
shows up cue another four loki team up we beat
her then thanos shows up we don't need him and i
die thanos kills half the universe the avengers go
back in time to stop him giving an earlier version
of me a chance to grab the test right off hang on
okay that's better thanos gets defeated
and the next thing you know i've got
a job offer from some group that
calls itself the tva and that's it
find out what happens next by streaming
loki exclusively on disney plus
Welcome back everyone burton with glorious
trailers we have a brand new loki trailer
to break down with a whole bunch of new footage
him talking about his own death going up against
thanos so we'll break it all down if you're
brand new to the channel i'll be doing videos for
all the episodes so be sure to subscribe to get
everything it's going to start in a couple weeks
the drought will be over we kind of went about
six weeks without any new marvel episodes it was
pretty weird there's so much marvel stuff coming
this year there will be very few breaks between
the next couple of marvel disney plus series
in the marvel movies that we're finally getting
finally getting some movies but i also love
in this trailer how he's joking about people
pirating the show like watch it exclusively
wink on disney plus it's a very loki thing to
do he knows exactly what's going on out there i
am doing a giveaway for disney plus memberships
by the way in all my loki episodes all you have
to do to enter that is just be a subscriber
and leave all your theories about the series on
the video but it seems like mobius own wilson's
character is actually showing this variant loki
the main loki of the series from avengers end game
his own death as it was supposed to happen
during the events of avengers infinity war
so during the clip obviously he covers
that part of his timeline we face thanos
didn't win i died he's talking about the original
version of loki the one that we think of is the
main loki that we've been watching this whole
time in all the marvel movies this one became
a variant when he stole the tesseract and used
the space stone to escape per the rules of time
travel in the way time works in the mcu as given
to us by the ancient one during endgame i'm sure
there's going to be a ton of questions about how
time travel works the rules they kind of set that
up during endgame but they're going to clarify a
lot of those rules during the loki series but when
he stole the space stone that created a bunch of
alternate timelines which each function like fully
alternate realities alternate universes and the
idea is they want to get rid of those because the
future versions of himself and all those alternate
timelines are way worse than he is right now
so part of the pitch that mobius is giving loki
here in his debriefing after the trial is to show
him the major events of his life like sitting him
down to do a re-watch of all the marvel movies
big marathon a lot of you probably did that last
year during 2020 because we all got stuck in our
homes for a hot minute during the lockdown but
it wasn't clear until we started getting more
footage of this scene but you can actually see
that this particular scene here is a good example
when they're watching the highlight reel this
scene is actually from the events of thor ragnarok
which haven't happened yet for this version of
loki the series takes place right after he steals
the tesseract at avengers end game but that was
during 2012 at the end of the first avengers movie
so he hasn't experienced the events of
thor ragnarok or avengers infinity war yet
i know there are a ton of questions about him
using the space stone to time travel so i'll
clarify that when the series starts because the
way they pitch the series i think there's some
misconceptions about what's happening with the
space stone all the time travel on the series is
happening because of the technology that the time
variance authority uses which kind of looks like
they're using quantum energy just the portals are
the same color as a lot of the quantum energy that
the avengers use to time travel and the quantum
energy you see in the quantum realm during ant-man
and the wasp but if mobius is showing him his
future that he was supposed to have had were he
to not have stolen the infinity stone he'd also
eventually find out how he was killed by thanos
trying to sacrifice himself to save thor and the
rest of the universe in an act of true heroism
that's the whole reason why mobius is willing
to take a shot on him because he saw that all
play out the time parents authority in the series
exists outside of normal space time so the kind
of inside a pocket dimension of sorts they were
created before the heat death of the main mcu
universe by the time keepers these beings that you
see here the lizard beings that loki was joking
about in that last clip space lizards so they got
a complete record of everything that ever happened
to anyone to anything inside the universe all the
way from the big bang the creation of the universe
the creation of the celestials all the way to the
end of time in this universe the heat death until
you have another contraction in another big bang
cycle where a new universe is born so i know the
next question is if they saw everything that ever
happened why didn't the time variance authority
try to stop thanos from snapping the infinity
gauntlet in avengers infinity war avengers
end game and why didn't they arrest the avengers
when they went back in time to steal the infinity
stones and assemble the new infinity gauntlet
because you'd think that some other person in the
future like king the conqueror would also think to
use that same plan like i'll just travel back in
time steal the infinity stones from different
points in history before thanos atomized them
and do whatever i want to with reality the main
reason why the tva didn't go after thanos in the
first place is because thanos technically was
not altering this timeline the infinity stones
as explained by the ancient one help create the
normal flow of time in each universe where they
exist so snapping the infinity gauntlet might
alter reality in the universe in some way but it
doesn't create new branch timelines per the rules
that marvel's using for time travel in the mcu
and because the tva exists outside of normal space
time they were protected from the effects of the
infinity gauntlet all the infinity gauntlet snaps
all four of them that we know about so you could
snap the gauntlet a hundred more times and alter
reality however you wanted and it still wouldn't
affect this place the time citadel so technically
thanos was not breaking any of their rules
more on this in a second because it does relate to
what loki was talking about in that other new clip
from episode one where he questions whether or not
the time keepers are the real villains in all this
like how dare you mess with the lives of
trillions of people all over the timeline but
also the reason why the tva didn't try to arrest
the avengers when they traveled back in time to
steal the infinity stones is because captain
america took all them back to where they stole
them from he even took mjolnir back to thor the
dark world thus erasing any potential alternate
timelines that they created when they stole them
in the first place that was one of the reasons
why the ancient one was willing to give the hook
the time stone because she trusted that they would
do the right thing and eventually bring it back
the reason why it's such a big deal that this
loki stole the space stone when normally they just
erase him and take the space stone back to where
he stole it from in the first place is because
when this loki inadvertently created all these
branch realities he created another loki that does
threaten the time variance authority that's kind
of what they're implying here in the synopsis for
the series they say that he's being recruited to
take down an even greater threat greater threat
to the time variance authority than thanos in
the infinity gauntlet so i think this even greater
threat that they're describing as implied by some
of the different trailer scenes is either female
loki lady loki whatever you want to call her
or possibly another hidden version of loki that
they haven't revealed in the trailer footage yet
for example richard e grant is playing a
big character on the series and there was
a rumor that he's playing what they're calling
classic loki who's meant to be a version of og
jack kirby looking loki he could wind up being one
of the bigger villains on the series female loki
though lady loki she seems like more of an agatha
harkness type of character i think she's the one
in all these different scenes in the hood who's
running through the halls of the tva you also
see her taking out some of these agents and other
scenes using tva technology and portals so when i
say she seems like more of an agatha harkness type
of character she seems really important for the
plot much more important than some of these other
alternate loki's like the more comedic versions
like president loki and just like agatha the
hardness she comes off as an antagonist but not
a super evil villain in the way that thanos
was evil like you understood his perspective
he saw this big problem overpopulation it's just
that his solution while effective was psychopathic
agatha harkness was more of an anti-hero type
of character that was trying to manipulate
scarlet witch so she was doing a lot of really bad
things she did wind up killing a bunch of people
over the years but after the explainer that they
give you in her flashback scene in salem you
find out that all she really wanted to at least
initially was just to learn more about her power
so she's a little bit like baron zemo more of
an anti-hero you understand his perspective
but also what he's doing is very bad like he winds
up killing a ton of people so that's kind of been
marvel's mo with the way they treat their villains
on these disney plus series their antagonists so
i'm expecting similar treatment with this version
of lady loki on the series and we might get some
more footage with her early on i think they'll
tease what's going on with her during episode one
but in the way that you didn't really find out
what was going on with agatha harkness till a
couple episodes into wandavision i think it'll
be the same deal with lady loki we won't really
find out what's going on with her until a couple
episodes in so she might be the one that's messing
with the tva threatening to take them down but
early theory variant loki here will probably find
out that he was correct in his assumption that
the timekeepers aren't totally good themselves and
start to empathize with some of these alternate
loki's that he's kind of being sent around to kill
they're basically sending him around to close down
these alternate timelines which would erase these
alternate loki's from existence so he's kind of
going around killing other versions of himself and
i think the whole reason why they need him the
whole idea is because lady loki or potentially
another alternate loki who's even worse is beating
the crap out of them and their solution is just
to send a loki to catch a loki the only other
character who's really pulled one over on the tva
is actually king the conqueror in the comics in
the future he was able to basically take them over
and take command of all time but if we see any
really big king the conqueror easter eggs in the
series of course i'll point those out i'm not
really expecting to see a ton of kang of the
conqueror until we get to ant-man 3 quantum
mania but everybody post all your theories
in the comments below who do you think the main
villain of this loki series is going to be which
alternate version of loki or do you think it's
actually going to be the time keepers themselves
that wind up being the real villains that was kind
of what they did with Wandavision like they made
tyler hayward seem like the actual villain and
i get the harkness seem more like an anti-hero
but the other big news you probably saw is that
supposedly there's going to be a new marvel
eternals trailer this week so if that does wind
up releasing of course i'll do a video for it
there's also supposed to be a new spider-man 3
no way home trailer sometime in the next couple
of weeks there was also a brand new rick and morty
season 5 trailer that just released so i'll do a
video for that next so make sure you have alerts
enabled so you don't miss any of those brand new
trailers that are coming there's going to be
a lot of really cool stuff happening the next
couple of weeks everyone click here for my video
on those other loki episode 1 scenes and brand
new footage that just released and click here for
my brand new doctor strange 2 shoe mcgorth video
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight!